so Colin Kapernick was sitting and then
one individual counseled him to kneel
instead and that person was Nate boy
who's joining me here on the Rich Eisen
show right now how are you sir
are you doing great Nate I gotta tell
you man world is crazy and I seek
counsel in you I'm not gonna lie and I
know you seek counsel and others and you
try to give counsel to others and you
need counsel yourself but I guess that's
why we're all joining together here is
you do all the time with the glaze for
merging vets and players I mean my gosh
if we're not merging this more than ever
it's now merging society so let's walk
through this here because apparently we
we need a tutorial again about why
Kaepernick was doing what he was doing
and what he was doing it to bring
attention to so how did you get hooked
up with Colin Kaepernick Nate I think I
think the difference you were talking
about I think I think well drew plays
football and LeBron plays bass yeah
there could be banging - yeah that's
true okay that could be that Nate it
could be that you know as we're
constantly in search for that sort of
thing how did you first get hooked up
with Colin Kaepernick yeah this was a
the preseason of NFL preseason at 2016
so I think important context for that is
it's a couple of months out of the
election you know which is we're in
another election year which is
interesting and obviously it was you
know whose team Hillary versus team
Trump
and our country had already experienced
you know quite a bit of division leading
up to this to this moment anyway I felt
like we were already being kind of
pulled apart which is frustrating is I
think almost any person who served in
the military will tell you regardless of
their politics most of us just we'd want
unity man we want our country to be
together we want them to support us and
you know and feel that and it didn't
feel like that in our society at the
time and you know and then Colin started
sitting on the bench during the national
anthem protesting police brutality
social inequality or so sorry social
injustice race
in equality and you know he made that
pretty clear but of course with social
media becoming now the mainstream media
it doesn't matter because people see an
image or or take a little sound bite or
something and it's just the narrative
changes and three and a half years later
now as we can see that the narrative
it's still hard to stay on task here and
keep the narrative what it's supposed to
be keep it keep it keep it real so
anyway I I wrote this open letter to
Colin explaining my experiences in the
military explaining why I feel the way
that I do during the anthem and why I
stand with my hand in my heart and feel
a certain way but also like I don't know
what it's like to feel like you feel and
I'll never pretend you know for me to
pretend what concealed what it's like to
be a person of color in this country is
as ignorant as someone telling me they
know what it's like to go to war that
you know it's never show day in the
military and so I think it resonated
with Colin and you know he reached out
to me and he wanted to meet so I went
down to San Diego before the final
preseason game of 2016 and it's the it's
its Military Appreciation Night because
9/11 was approaching there's a flyover
Navy SEALs jumping into the stadium
there's like this Navy Band on the field
with an african-american man gonna sing
the national anthem and this whole
thing's going on and Colin you know and
I are chatting a few hours before the
game in the hotel lobby and you know we
talked about some of the things I just
discussed like are both of our
background why he feels the way that he
feels why I feel the way that I feel but
you know more than anything I was just
trying to listen to where he was coming
from with all this and he was pretty
clear on that and I understood he is
also very clear that he's insane that
look I've committed to not standing
until I see things change I'm not going
to and and you know I said okay I
respect that I mean at the end of the
day when I took an oath to defend the
Constitution it that includes the First
Amendment and freedom of speech and
everybody that served in the military
that's what we thought well we don't
have to agree with it we don't have to
like it all the time but we fought for
these rights and so I respect that and
he asked me at the end of this
conversation do you think there's
another way I could demonstrate like
approach you show my protest
without offending people in the military
and they said no there's nothing you can
do that's not going to send some people
and I said even if you stood at this
point you're going to offend some people
people are going to think that you know
you gave up on your protest you're not
committed you're not a man of conviction
so you know I said the only other thing
I could think of to me and I don't speak
to the military or the veteran community
or anybody but myself to me I think
being alongside your teammates is the
most important thing and if that's the
case and you're not going and you say
you're not going to stand it's the only
other option you really have is taken to
me and it's you know people take a knee
to pray and propose to their wives and
we'll take a knee in front of a fallen
brother's grave to pay respect in the
military it seemed like a common sign of
respect and he agreed that was more
powerful he asked me if I'd join him I
told him I want to I want to stand
because of the way that I feel and I I
don't want to kneel but I'll stand next
to you because I support what you're
doing and you're right and and I also
want to see this country be better and
get better and so I did that and that's
that was the first night he ever knelt
and obviously you know it's pretty cool
today the elastoplastic to see a lot of
people in the community they don't look
like him
law enforcement officers taken me at
times and it's been a unifying symbol in
a lot of ways which is ironic because a
lot of people thought it is the complete
opposite when it first happened
Nate Boyer here on the Rich Eisen show
Green Beret and also co-founder of
merging vets and players with Jay Glazer
right here on the Rich Eisen show did at
any point Collins say I don't like the
military to you no no no right so I
guess you heard my sigh you know what
I'm saying like so you were standing
next to him that night right yes okay
and what what did he say anything to you
after the anthem look at you did you
share a moment but what what happened
after that yeah I mean you know to be
completely honest he was nervous going
into it and so was I and and I and I
understand his nerves
I mean mine I think a little bit less I
understood it at the time I think I
just like didn't know what to expect I
also with like worried about my
Brotherhood you know the Special Forces
community specifically because more than
anything besides probably my parents I
hate disappointing them and making and
having them feel like I'm not
representing them in a good way so I I
was nervous about that you know and
that's kind of a selfish thing it's not
that big a deal it's not like that
that's not a it's not the same it's like
why he's taking to me you know that was
just a selfish like I want people to
like me but I was nervous about that and
then to hear some of the people in the
stand who you know and I heard that
that's that's what I heard over
everything else and there wasn't several
in the majority of people booing if I
wasn't even that many people but that's
what I focused on and that that bothered
me that bothered me a lot more than
anybody taking me you know what I mean
and you know and then after it happened
after the anthem was done he stood up
and gave me five he had it he had a bit
of a nervous smile of his face right
maybe it was because he was starting
that night he's trying to win his job
back I don't know yeah could be you know
but uh but I felt that too and I was
like man this is but I felt proud too
I also felt proud after it was over and
he was I out on the field and other
players in the team white/black didn't
matter they were coming up to me and you
know I'm shaking my hand saying nice to
nice to meet you appreciate what you're
doing I had a nice conversation with
Torrey Smith who was on the Niners at
the time and so that was cool I was very
settling for me and I felt like I
belonged on that sideline you know in a
lot of ways and anyway that was just
that was the emotions of the day and I
wouldn't change a thing to be honest no
and and clearly what we saw has sparked
a conversation but and I and again Drew
Brees has apologized for what he said
but the fact that he said what he said
yesterday makes it seem like he didn't
understand and still doesn't and that
and I think gives a lot of voice to a
lot of people who still do not
understand why Colin Kaepernick took a
knee now we know why he took a knee as
opposed to sitting or at least reminding
people of that since this has been
public knowledge for a while and we feel
the need to repeat this but why he took
on mean
um why do you think people still have
such a difficult time Nate coming from
obviously a military background that you
have but you also have a football
background you have a background of
being around a diverse group I've seen
the merging vets and players meetings it
is a tapestry of veterans from the
military as well as sports why do you
feel this is still not sunk in why
Kaepernick and decided to take a knee
and what he was trying to bring
attention to even though that's all over
the streets of America right now Nate
right yeah I mean first of all the
veteran community is the most diverse
microcosm in the country as you know you
know just um seeing the vets at MVP but
it's true like we are we look like
everything we're from everywhere we
believe all kinds of different stuff but
for the most part we're able to put all
that crap aside and we'll take a bullet
for one another even if we don't like
each other you know II know pretty much
disagree with everything and would never
have it we would never have a beer
offline and hang out but we're still
willing to do that and so like that's an
important distinction there to make but
you know and when it pertains to the
anthem and the flag no I feel the exact
same way drew brees does when the song
is played and the anthem and the flag is
raised and that's not a bad thing
there's not no I want to say this too so
do i and then at a stadium when the
national anthem is played and you know
my kids were there my wife and I they
they stand up they take their hats off
they put their hands over their heart
that's the way I do it but I would
understand if a person next to me took a
knee um I I would explain to my children
well my kids already would know what
they're doing
because they you know we explain to them
what's going on in the world and why
Kaepernick did what he did and so on and
so forth but I I make them stand up hand
over
so I understand again why that is but I
also understand why cap Kapernick or
another individual be taking a knee
during that moment right so I just I'm
sorry I just wanted to interrupt right
there and now please go on this is a
conversation it's important because a
lot of people feel that when I don't
want people to think that like the last
thing I want is anybody to feel nervous
or like they're wrong for feeling
patriotic because I feel big time you
know and I love this country and it's I
do believe it's the greatest country in
the world doesn't mean we can't do a
hell of a lot better but I do believe
that and I feel those same things that
he felt but at the same time it is not
just because I feel it it doesn't it
doesn't mean everybody just should or
has to or their experiences are even
close to the same as mine that would
lead them to feel you know even a
semblance of that same way and so if
somebody doesn't feel that way
I'm gonna do everything in my power so
that they do you know that's it like I
want them I want everybody to feel like
I do I don't want anything anybody to do
anything ever out of obligation that's
just not my way it's not the American
Way shouldn't be so when it pertains to
the narrative like that that's the most
frustrating thing so I think a lot of
these these men not just in the league
but and when I should take people across
the country just human beings that the
what this is all about it's been
continued continually hammered home and
it's still you know that the narratives
still twisted as like oh they're just
disrespecting the flag at a
disrespecting you know it's like been
clearly stated that's not what this is
about it's not what it's about
we've seen plenty of signs and symbols
throughout our history of I guess you
can call it descent you know anything we
look back on those things and we're like
wow that was powerful you know what a
brave thing to do yet in this moment at
this time for whatever reason like a lot
of people I just don't want to accept
that this is this is that person's truth
and what this person is trying to do is
not a bad thing not a wrong thing it's
it's all about it's a patriotic thing
you know and I that's it that's a scary
word nowadays too but it's a patriotic
thing to do that not just because we
have the rights of
protests but because what's behind that
is a belief and a feeling that this
country can do better and that we can be
more unified and then we can be more
equal and that everyone can feel the
same type of opportunities that I feel
because I feel like in this country I
can chase any dream I want you know that
American dream is we got a lot we all
got our own American dream but not
everybody feels like it's possible for
them and that's not right that's not
fair you know and just because you do or
for someone else that I do doesn't mean
that's so you know just doesn't mean
it's over everybody and so we just have
to acknowledge that and understand that
and then do what we can to listen to
everybody and fight for those that that
don't have it you know together that's
the best thing we can do and it's not an
easy thing to do but but we've got to
try I agree with you Nate boy or I I
agree with you when was the last time
you spoke with Kaepernick when was the
last time you and he actually connected
was it that actual night no you know we
it's been a couple of years we talked on
and off throughout the season and I'm in
a little bit kind of early the next
season when you know when president
Trump had the the sons of [ __ ]
comment and all that of course it
stirred up again
I think I'm not even close to like
things are now because that was more
just a lot of talk a lot of social media
and now we're seeing a lot more action
people on the streets which is great you
know I love that aside from the social
distancing stuff all right whatever it
is what it is
I I think it's but that's what I've
always said without action behind it
it's just an empty gesture you know and
Collins always had plenty of action
behind it whether I think what he said
and done is in the best way of doing it
doesn't matter you know but he's been
doing something and a lot and all these
players I haven't seen a player in the
league that's spoken out or taking the
knee or whatever that's not doing
something in the community so to address
this issue which is important so that
should be for every American you know
and everybody overseas that's that's
involved in this thing which is kind of
crazy to see all you know all the
continents everywhere there's something
is going on in support of this message
which is really cool so continue to
action you know continue to action
behind that
now it's like the next step it's not
just going on a marsh in the streets
it's like what are you doing involving
your community like how are you even if
it's just one-on-one conversation with
somebody in learning or take it to the
next step you know getting involved in
policy changes or whatever like that's
that's how it happens
and it all didn't all start it started
hundreds of years ago but it's a
continued commitment from people like
Colin Kapernick and so many others to
kind of lay it all out there and risk
risk something something pretty big for
for them and for for a lot of people to
keep the conversation going and and the
changes to keep coming because things
have changed things have changed over
hundreds of years I'm not saying I would
never say the things have not changed
and and things are you know even even
since the civil rights movement things
are better but they're they're way far
away from where they need to be well and
in turn keep moving forward in terms of
things changing I'd be remiss if I
didn't ask you this Nate and I know this
is somewhat outside of what we're what
we're talking about then the Kapernick
in the kneeling but what do you think of
seeing tanks on the streets in American
cities the use of a medical helicopter
as we saw a couple of nights ago in
Washington DC to either intimidate or
disperse a peaceable assembly people
with without names or insignia zhan
uniforms but in in roles of enforcement
on the streets what do you think of that
as somebody who's fought overseas me
it's scary in a lot of ways and
something I think about immediately is
when I was at Texas going to college and
playing football I was still in the
military I was in the National Guard and
I was going overseas I'm going to
Afghanistan every summer and coming back
and going to school and playing football
for the four years I was there and if
this would have happened during that
time there's a chance I'd have been
called up right mm-hm and so I be in the
streets of Austin Texas maybe dressed
like one of these people and and doing
my job you know serving my country doing
what I took the oath to do and what it
slow
to mean to me is protecting you know
just like law enforcement supposed to be
protecting and serving defending
people's rights to protest peacefully
and all that right but also when there's
you know when there's when there's
people looting when there's people doing
things that they shouldn't be doing you
know you're there to protect against
that of course but I don't none of those
most of those people don't want to be
there they don't want to do that they
don't want to patrol those streets they
don't we don't know what military in Our
Strength's it takes like are you nuts
that's the opposite I want to come home
from war and get as far away from that
as possible and I think a lot of these
people feel that same way and so that's
a that's a scary thing in it and it's
tough and I feel for a lot of them
because that's a very diverse group as I
said earlier too you know that that
group of people in those uniforms they
don't all think the same way that
they're a lot of them are scared you
know and yeah I feel for them but just
like in the law enforcement just like in
the NFL in the military there are
certain people that shouldn't be wearing
that uniform they just should you know
they don't they don't do it the right
way they don't represent with that
uniform supposed to represent they don't
represent the flag the way that it's
supposed to be represented and we've got
to do what we can in society in every
industry to get that cleaned up get
those people out of those positions
especially ones that have a you know a
pretty high up tuition and and so it's
on us it's on all of us to like to do
that you know
and with the fact that this officer
shopping was even working it's just
pretty appalling you know that it was
even working in on the streets and when
you see what happened what happened with
George would it's incredibly sad when
you look at the background and read the
record officer shop and it's not
surprising and that's bad that's a bad
thing that's a scary thing but we've got
those people everywhere we've got them
in the military too we're not all heroes
you know so I'll be the first one to
admit that and and I'm not a hero I'm
saying I'm a hero in any way but like
we've got we've got to do a better job
as a country making sure the people on
our left and right when we trust with
our lives and we're out there to protect
us and we're out there to look after us
not to
and law enforcement in the military are
those that that truly care about America
truly care about everybody equally and
at least as close as they can and and
let's just let's just get that cleaned
up let's get that fix you know we've got
a lot of people out of work right now
that should be in work we've got a lot
of people in work right now that
shouldn't be Nate what you are is a
great American great human man that's
what you are vets and players org to
learn more about merging vets and
players you co-founded it along with Jay
Glazer because you both realized that
there are individuals in sports and in
the military who are trying to find
purpose once they are done with what
they thought their sole purpose on this
earth was and what you guys do I've seen
it my wife and I have seen it what I
know about you everyone should know
about vets and players org it's a
beautiful wonderful organization and I
can't thank you enough always for
calling in and sharing your thoughts and
I can only imagine I know you say you're
not a hero brother but I can only
imagine what it's like when you turn on
televisions and see peaceful protests
thousands of people thousands of people
now all over the world pausing in
reflection taking a knee on the ground I
can only imagine what that must mean for
you to you and to those you represent
and I say to you thank you thank you
rich I appreciate that but yeah I truly
believe the veteran community an athlete
community can come together to continue
to push this conversation forward and
solve a lot of these issues in the
country lead the way at least in solving
a lot of these issues in the country
that we we're leaders and we need to act
that way even after the uniform comes up
make you take care of yourself
I'll stay in touch you do - please okay
- thank you so much brother you got a
knack Nate border 37 for those who want
to follow Nate on Twitter I do you
should as well